welcome to myths and metaphors of open
source this is a talk about the way
language metaphors and math shape open
source and about the way they shape the
way we think about open source and the
value that we place on open-source
maintainer z' and the work that they do
my name is Daniel Compton I am an open
source project maintainer I am a
volunteer admin at closures closures is
kind of like ruby gems for closure I
work at a new startup code named Falcon
and I am the project leader of an
organization called closures together
closures together is an organization
designed to help fund open-source
closure software I'm going to talk more
about that very soon first I'd like to
talk briefly Falcon proj is a closure
based startup we're doing work still and
stealth but hiring closure engineers
remotely across u.s. time zones so if
you'd like to work with closure remotely
come talk with me afterwards or check
out Falcon proj so my story started a
few years ago with seeing people
starting to say things like this I'm
exhausted
but want to keep going they were talking
about their open-source work and they
really cared about it they wanted to be
doing this but it was just too much they
were getting burned out they were
putting in all of this time and effort
and they perhaps didn't feel appreciated
or didn't feel like they had the support
they needed and so this I could see this
in the closure community and beyond but
I thought you know I can I can start
with closure so along with several
others we created closures together in
late 2017 to fund open source closure
projects particularly ones that were
important to a large part of the closure
community and so far thanks to generous
member support we've given 15 grants to
closure projects and we've funded over
$100,000 of open source closure software
development and working on this project
I've gotten to talk to lots of people
about funding open source open source
value and I started to understand a
little bit about how people think about
open source and met I've got some ideas
about maybe
a well we don't value it as highly as we
could but first I'd like to talk about
how the brain works or at least how we
thought it worked this is a Roman
bathhouse this is about 2,000 years ago
the Romans were very famous for their
plumbing this was you know one of their
pinnacles of their technological
achievement and they also liked their
baths and so they created bath houses
they created plumbing throughout you
know the Roman Empire and this was when
if you are a Roman at that time and you
think about what's the most advanced
technology that you can think of you
know plumbing is going to be up there
and so when the Roman medical people and
philosophers started to think about what
is the brain like they thought well you
know maybe it's a bit like a hydraulic
system you know there's you know fluid
inside the body we know that when we cut
people you know stuff comes out and so
maybe the brain works this way too maybe
there are little you know tubes running
through your body pumping fluid around
it to make the brain work and they
weren't you know completely wrong but
they this was you know not really going
on the right track either and this makes
it difficult to develop a stronger
theory about how the body works there's
a great quote from Hippocrates and his
book on the nature of man sneezing
arises from the head owing to the brain
being heated or filled with moisture so
the ear inside overflows and makes a
noise because it passes through a narrow
place this is the nose so this was their
theory about you know why do we sneeze
is because you know there's too much
moisture and fluid inside the heat so
you can see if you have the wrong
metaphor if you start in the wrong place
then you can end up with some very
confused ideas if we move forward a
little bit this is a old telegraph
system or sorry phone system and around
this time people were looking at the
brain and starting to see axons and
dendrites the little electrical impulses
flowing in the brain and so they started
to think well maybe the brain is like a
telephone system you know there's a you
know an operator they're switching the
around and this is what makes the brain
work and again they weren't you know
completely wrong but this was you know
far short of their you know what the
brain is capable of end doesn't really
give you a lot of insight into the brain
beyond this and this is a mainframe and
mainframes in computers are now the
common metaphor that we use for the
brain we say that you know we do
thinking which is a little bit like the
CPU we have short-term memory which is
like RAM and we have long-term memory
which is like a hard disk and again this
is not completely wrong but if you think
too much about the brain being a
computer then you're going to end up
missing some really vital aspects of how
the brain works how the body works and
for example our memories are not perfect
they are associative and the our brains
not multi-threaded switching tasks and
the brain is extremely expensive and if
you just think of your brain as you know
just just like a computer then you're
gonna again end up in some confused
places and what we see from this is that
the language you use is not just a
passive descriptor the metaphors we use
shape the way we think about things and
they shape the way we think about our
world and so what are the metaphors of
computing computing is largely you know
a non-physical realm most of the time
we're not dealing with matter in the
world we're dealing with virtual bits on
disk and so it's largely defined by the
language and the constructs that we
create for it and we don't have a lot of
physical artifacts of the work that we
do one of the most enduring metaphors in
computing is the disk top metaphor this
is from a Xerox star back in 1981 and
they took icons they made icons which
looked like things that you would see in
an office and created applications
behind this so you can see things from a
an office at that time you know paper
filing cabinets manila folders
in and out trays and pocket calculators
and this has been a really durable
metaphor you can see 40 years into the
future the iPhone if you squint a little
bit it kind of looks like it's you know
basically the same thing you've got a
row of icons with pictures on the front
describing what they do and what I
really like about this in particular is
if you see their their calculator icon
from the Xerox star doesn't even really
look out of place on an iPhone from
today another durable metaphor is that
of the teletype the teletype was an
electromechanical device it came around
before mainframes it was used for
sending telegrams but when mainframes
were being developed they repurposed
this teletype to send and receive
messages to and from the mainframe and
this teletype is what we use today or
what we are emulating today when we use
a command line it's a remarkably durable
abstraction because it has proved so
useful and so these two things the
command line in the disk top are two
different ways of thinking about the
computer and interacting with it and
they change the way that you think about
computing each of them have distinct
benefits and they open up different
possibilities and constrain others and
computing has its own set of myths this
is the jargon file and who's read this
before seen this pretty much everyone so
this is written by Eric Raymond who also
wrote the cathedral and the bazaar and
in it he talks about this what I'm gonna
call it a myth of the real UNIX hecka
and this person is someone who writes
and C they do system software they use
the command line you know they are close
to the middle and this is not wrong you
know they're certainly people like this
I had breakfast with one really nice
person this morning who does this kind
of stuff and that's great but I think
this does myth of the UNIX Hecker as
being a true this is the true programmer
has been incredibly powerful incredibly
long-lasting in
incredibly damaging and it's constrained
the way we think about computing and who
can be a programmer and what programming
is an open source is full of its own
metaphors to one of the most dominant
metaphors as that of competition and
ever since I've been aware of open
source software it's always been in
competition with closed source software
there's a competition of you know is
open source gonna win as closed source
gonna win and even within programming
languages you know is it Ruby or Python
or closure or Java you know there's a
constant tension and rivalry between
programming languages and then even
within a programming community we have
rivalries and tensions and there's this
assumption deeply baked assumption that
growth is good that user growth is the
most important thing for a programming
language community or a technical
community in general in the way we use
this language influences how we and
others think about open source this is a
a Commons and England and the Commons
you may have heard of the tragedy of the
Commons it's not always so clear what
the Commons actually was and the Commons
was a real thing it was common land
owned by one person but which another
set of people had rights over and so
they were allowed to graze their sheep
or clicked firewood or fish on it or
different they had different sets of
rights and it was common land
collectively owned or collectively able
to be used but owned by someone else and
so there was a theory economic theory
that the Commons was unsustainable that
it wasn't possible to have this shared
resource where people were going to
overuse it and destroy it for others if
there wasn't a private control over that
and so I guess there's two problems with
that firstly this was you know pretty
thoroughly debunked by Elinor Ostrom
who got a Nobel Prize for her work on
you know common public goods and how
they can be shared and can work as a
public resource and secondly this kind
of metaphor presupposes that we have a
scarce good and when you apply this to
open source software
it really falls down because open-source
software has no imaginal costs of
distribution if one of you takes you
know a download of nginx and starts
using it it doesn't take away anything
from anybody else you can't overuse
engine x2 you take it to damage anybody
else's ability to use engine X another
metaphor this one I really do like is
that of infrastructure and you may have
read Nadia Igbos work on roads and
bridges which is about the critical
infrastructure underpinning large parts
of society which is often open source
work and often underappreciated and the
funded ends not necessarily maintained
very well and so I think this her work
has brought forward people's attention
and understanding of the need for us to
be maintaining open source software over
time and one of the ways that people
will think about funding open source
software is through donations and well I
think you know it's great when people do
get donations
I think donations can be the wrong way
to frame things donations typically our
thought of as charity they thought of as
providing value to somebody else but
they're not we're not doing it for
ourselves we're not getting anything in
return we are just giving the money
because it's a good thing to do which is
great but I think if we do this we miss
some of the some of the benefit of open
source in some of the reasons why we
would want to fund it it's not just
because it's a good thing to do but if
you're using this open source you
personally add deriving value from it as
well another metaphor for open source is
patronage and patronage was much more
common about you know four or five
hundred years ago in Renaissance times
where you if you were an artist or a
musician you probably couldn't make
money selling your artwork or music
directly and what would happen is that
there would be rich patrons who would
sponsor you 14 or 20 years perhaps and
they would pay for your materials they
would give you a place to live they
would give you a stipend to to work
and in exchange you would create your
art for them your creators buy them
directly for them or you would create it
and it would be you know knowing that
they were the ones who had sponsored
this work and this was great know we got
you know many many beautiful pieces of
artwork and music and all sorts of
things created through this but there
are some downsides to the patronage
relationship this is a painting of the
School of Athens by Raphael who was who
had the Medici family was his patrons
and this is many scholars this is a
painting of ancient scholars and
philosophers arguing and debating and in
a temple and what's really interesting
at this is this person here is not a
scholar or a philosopher this is the
Pope at the times nephew and the Duke of
Urbino and he was drawn in there not
because he was a you know famed scholar
or a famed mind he wasn't even from the
right generation you know he was you
know fifteen hundred years too recent to
fit him with the rest of these people
but because of this because of this
influence from the patrons he was he was
drawn in there either to curry favor
with his patrons or perhaps he was even
asked to be drawn in there and the first
thing you might think about anything of
patronage and open source is patreon and
patron yes uses some of the same
language but I think a much better
analogy as there of corporate
sponsorship of open source developers
where often companies will hire the
maintainer zyv open source projects and
let them just kind of work on it on
company time for half time or full time
perhaps and this is great you know we've
gotten a lot of great things out of this
but the risk here is that you as an
employee of that company either make
changes to the software to suit your
company's needs
either because someone has asked you or
maybe you just kind of can feel it in
the water and you know that if you did
this particular change it wouldn't be
received very well so there's problems
of influence there if you you know if
all of your funding comes from just a
single pad
another metaphor for open source this
one does not generally talked about
directly but I think this is a mindset
that a lot of people have when they do
open source or use open source software
is that of a vending machine and this is
this idea is that open source is all
about consumer choice there's a bunch of
libraries that you can go along and peck
and the most important thing is that
you're able to get up and running
quickly you're able to consume the
software easily
it's a homogeneous work method of
downloading and installing and working
with the software and what's important
is that you can solve your problem
downloaded a pendency and then move on
with the rest of your day and there's
not really much of a relationship
between you and a vending machine you
know transactions there boom you're gone
and I think this is this is perhaps some
of the reasons why we have problems and
open source software where maintain is
aren't really feeling like they are very
appreciated because for the most part
people just download the software and
the only time they show up is when
there's a problem and open source is
this really special thing we don't
really have many other things in the
world like this where you can create
something of real value of your true
deep value that can be used by anyone in
the world without that being used up you
can share it and share it again and each
time it doesn't take anything away from
anybody else there's not a lot of things
like this and so this is this is
fundamentally a generous act to share
your software with the world and I think
it's special I think it's something we
need to protect and we need to be a
little bit careful about when we talk
about funding open source and open
source sustainability I think there's a
risk that if we that we need to be
careful about how we do that so we don't
lose this you know this nature of open
source open source has its own set of
interfaces that we work with and these
are going to be taken from github
because github is largely the dominant
creative place where open source was
created and used
and contributed to first one here is the
issue tracker and we can see on the left
that github issue tracker and on the
right we have the JIRA issue tracker and
you can see straight away there's quite
a difference between the two on the Left
we have a title and an empty text field
and on the right in the JIRA issue
tracker there's ten fields there and we
still even haven't even got to typing
about the actual problem we have and
these are design decisions that's the
creators of this software have made and
they've done so and they put different
burdens of work on the creators of the
open-source versus their people who are
posting these issues and github you can
type just about whatever you like into
these text fields click Submit and now
it's on the maintainer plate they need
to look at it they need to figure out is
this a problem as this actionable can I
do anything about this did they even
post this to the right project and with
it where the JIRA side you've got a lot
more work needing that you need to do at
front before you can even you know click
the submit button in either of these are
necessarily wrong but the design
decisions we make building these
platforms change the way that people
interact with it and so when you're
building systems I think it's really
important to think about you know what
kind of patterns of behavior are we
encouraging or discouraging another way
another interface and github is this
contribution streaks the contribution
graph at the top is still there now but
the contribution streaks are gone and
this was done with the greatest of
intentions I believe but the idea was
that every day that you did work on open
source you would get a little green mark
on the graph and every day that you you
know consecutively worked on open source
including on the weekends you would
collect you build the streak up longer
and longer and so we can say this person
has worked for 177 days in a row on open
source work doing commits or opening
issues or PRS and what what we found or
what people started to realize was that
this was unsustainable
that they were staying to burn out they
were staying to feel really tired and
they couldn't go on but there were you
know pressures you know this is just you
know a silly little number
but yes you know it had had real effect
had an effect on me I remember doing
work on Saturdays and Sundays just so I
could keep that streak going
and ultimately github removed us they
realized I think that it was probably
doing more harm than good
and so we need to think a little bit
about the the platforms that we built
and Marshall McLuhan wrote this phrase
you've probably heard that before the
medium is the message and what it means
is that what is communicated is not just
the content delivered over the medium
but also the characteristics of the
medium itself the the framing that
github gives to the issue tracker
they're their way that they track your
contributions this is just as much part
of the message of open source as the
software being delivered through that
platform and this is why I'm really
excited to see github working on github
sponsors this is a new project that lets
you add anybody to support a project
into the github interface so you can see
there right next to the watching and
star buttons there is a button for
supporting a project and when you click
on it you see this you know dialog
pop-up and it shows you different ways
that you can support this project and
I'm really excited that github the
medium is sending this message that
funding open source is important and
when we created closures together we
adopted the metaphor of a grant making
organization this was a neutral
organization we didn't want to be
picking winners in the closure community
we wanted to you know spread the money
evenly where it was most needed and one
of the very first things we ran into was
an issue with how we communicated the
work that we were doing and we we
started off by saying we were going to
pay people 150 dollars an hour for 12
hours a month and this was going to work
out to $1,800 and the reason we chose
$150 an hour was firstly because we were
copying ruby together who came
for us and it seemed like a good idea
but also I really like the idea of
sending this message that encoded in
this 150 dollars an hour was the message
we're sending was this work is valuable
this is top tier software development
works the work that you are doing is an
open source developer is creating you
know value for thousands or tens of
thousands of people in the closure
community and we want to you know
respect that we can't perhaps offer you
a full-time salary but we want to say
that you know when you're working this
is what we think you're worth
unfortunately people perhaps didn't get
their message and they started saying
things like you're paying people too
much this is you know - you're you're
being too generous to open-source
project maintainer x' and they would say
things like you know you should pay them
you know I would do the work for $50 an
hour instead of one hundred and fifty
dollars an hour and this wasn't really
you know what we were going for we were
and we were funding the project
maintainer so we were finding the people
who were best suited to be doing this
work so we went back to the drawing
board and thought a little bit more
about this and we came up with a more
straightforward grant mechanism where we
would just pay the maintainer $1,800
each month and there was no hourly rate
attached there was no fixed number of
hours and this was fine it was exactly
the same amount of money in both cases
but the way that we had framed this you
know changed how people saw what we were
doing and when we're designing
open-source funding systems or
interacting with open-source maintained
as we need to think about the way that
we communicate the value that we are
doing and so this talk has been talking
about funding open source and I've been
doing a lot of talk about the language
we use and the reason why is that the
language we use leads to different
feelings and perceptions and beliefs
about open source software and that
leads to what we think about which leads
to the decisions we make any actions
that we take to fund open source
software and so if we just start at the
bottom and say you know there's a
problem with the open source software
not being funded enough and we don't
attack it at the root of the problem
then I'm not sure you know if we're
gonna be able to you know really address
the issue and so
I think you know we need to think about
the whole system not just the part at
the end and if we believe that when we
need to design systems that reflect the
fact that open source is free but it's
not worthless and design systems that
recognize the value and the work being
provided and in the work that these
maintained errs are doing and so I'd
like to propose a new metaphor for open
source work which is that of partnership
partnership between the creators of open
source work and the users of open source
that it's an exchange of value that open
source users may be will contribute time
or money or attention or other things of
value that they have towards the open
source project and the open source
project in return creates software that
is valuable for them and a partnership
is generative it's something which
creates more value than you put in the
the and this is true of all good
partnerships and I think all good
partnerships can't are not transactional
either this is not I'm not proposing
that this becomes like a sign up system
where you you know to use open source
you have to like put down your name as I
am a partner of this open source project
I think it should be freely given I
think this is this is an opportunity if
you want to you can help support the
open source software that you work with
and see see it grow and see it gets
tremendously better but I don't think it
should be forced I think that this
should still be the ability to use open
source software without without this
forcing and these are some of the
partners of closures together pitch new
Bank Juxt who was speaking at the
conference mitosis --n ed goji and
funding circle these are some of the
companies that have worked with us its
closures together to help us so I'd
really like to say thanks to them so
what can you do the first thing is
consider how you talk about your open
source dependencies in your companies
when you're talking about projects think
about you know think of that there's
people on the other end of these
projects and you know what does that
mean how how should we talk about that
how should we
think about those people next thing is
talking to your work about supporting
the open source dependencies you use
that might be through putting time into
making a patch or fixing an issue or
triaging a bunch of the things that
people have posted where it's maybe not
even clear what they're trying to say
and or giving money to the project and
lastly think critically about the
messages and the mediums that you build
if you're building software for
developers or open source developers
then think about what are the patterns
of interaction that we're designing for
is this what we want to be happening and
I have a few acknowledgments firstly the
strange loop I really appreciate them
giving me their chance to speak about
this and talk at this conference and all
of the closures together members we have
hundreds of developer members and tens
of company members who have all given
money to help us you know create this
open-source work and taught us a lot
about funding open-source it also like
to thank Ruby together an Andre Arco in
particular Ruby together came before us
and we copied you know lots of what they
did and Andre Arco in particular has
given us a lot of time to help us you
know learn from what they've done I'd
like to think the software freedom
Conservancy they are our nonprofit
parents and so they provide a lot of the
financial and accounting and legal
support that you need when you are
distributing money all around the world
this is something which is not something
that I had really thought about until we
encountered that and it's an incredible
amount of work and you can often go very
underappreciated so yeah I really
appreciate them I'd also like to say
thanks to my wife I've spend a lot of
time maintaining open source software
and doing projects and there has
sometimes come at the cost of family
life and yeah she's been great about
giving me that time and looking after
the kids you know I'm here at this
conference you know and she's at home
with the kids and I feel you know pretty
conflicted about there and so let's say
thanks to to my wife and also to all of
the partners of open-source maintainer
z-- that have
given them time to do this work that we
have all benefited from I know many
people you know do this work in their
spare time and their free hours and so
I'd like to say thanks to everyone who
has done that
thank you
[Applause]